all right welcome back to the concluding
session of the taming the giant
corporation conference going to conclude
okay we're going to conclude the session
that we're gonna conclude we're going to
conclude the conference with a session
of a conversation between Amy Goodman
and Ralph Nader there's been a lot of
talk again about the structure of
corporations the harms perpetrated by
corporations strategies to subordinate
and displace corporations are two
overarching themes of the conference but
now we want to get and hopefully have a
very engaged and detailed discussion
about strategies and ways to move
forward so that there's no sense in
which the overarching power which we're
talking about and facing and trying to
confront and subordinate and displace
leave those feeling powerless because we
do collectively have more power as Ralph
suggested earlier in the conference if
we organize to obtain it I think that's
what some of what will emerge from the
conversation that follows Amy Goodman as
all of you know is the host of democracy
now
she's the hardest-working journalist in
this country
rustle no Khyber and I wrote a comma
while back saying that the CBS anchor
job should have been given to Amy and
not to Katie Couric people thought we
were joking we weren't joking that
wasn't funny I was serious Amy's been
doing well one thing about democracy now
that I mean people are listeners and
they know but I think what's so
remarkable about the show is the breadth
of issues that Amy covers the diversity
of people that she talks to and her
ability to go on the ground all across
the country all around the world find
victims of injustice and enable them to
tell their stories and facilitate people
coming together to build countervailing
power to take on large corporations and
address fundamental issues of war and
peace now as it happens Amy had a career
before starting democracy now a decade
and a half ago and it turns out she
wrote a full issue of multinational
monitor in 1985 based on work she had
done in college
the case against depo-provera drug that
was being pushed in the developing world
with devastating consequences she is now
in addition to the hosting democracy now
the author of several books most
recently static subtitle government
liars media cheerleaders and people who
fight back she'll be interviewing Ralph
Nader the consumer advocate Ralph has
written many books of his own one of the
recent books is the good fight and let
me just say in conclusion before turning
it over to the discussion that this
discussion and every part of the
conference has been recorded will be
available on DVD you can get information
at the websites that are listed here
obtain the corporation org and otherwise
and with that let's turn it over to Amy
and Ralph
I think if asked Ralph most people would
say today the most important issue of
the day is war war and peace so why have
a three-day conference on the
corporation well first of all the
corporations are very involved in the
war machine we remember remember
President Eisenhower's statement about
the military-industrial complex he might
have called it today the industrial
military complex because the industrial
part is now a supreme influence on the
US military budget which now is half of
the entire federal government's
operating budget and as well as
affecting foreign policy even mr. Koppel
has written that oil is very much
involved in the invasion of Iraq in fact
he went to say it's mostly about oil and
an op-ed in the New York Times Ted
Koppel so the domination the corporate
sovereignty over our political economy
is very much related to our foreign
military and economic policy including
GATT and NAFTA which are architectures
of corporate supremacy over civil values
and the rights of workers environment
and consumers can you recap from this
conference of three days people coming
at corporations dealing with them in
many different ways what you think are
the biggest problems and the most
effective strategies for dealing with
them well the biggest problem is that
the avenues to challenge corporate power
to restrain it to break it up in its
present concentrated form to take it
away from the political arena because
corporations are artificial entities and
not real human beings they don't vote
they don't die in Iraq they don't have
children there are entities that are
dominating our politics our electoral
systems our universities increasingly
dominate almost everything
even moving into areas that were once
prohibited by custom in our country like
commercializing childhood and so this
conference really challenges the
corporation's at every interface that
affects people taxpayers consumers
workers communities children health care
living wage the varieties of
opportunities that people should have
that are being denied we are in the
advanced stages of being a corporate
state where as Franklin doesn't Franklin
doll Rozsival warned Congress in 1938
that when government is controlled by
private economic power he called that
fascism and he would consider today's
controlled by private economic power
namely giant corporations astride the
world as an even more advanced form of
what he called fascism control of
government by corporate interests would
you call it fascism
the clinical definition as far as what
what he was saying it was it obviously
colored in different contexts in World
War two but the clinical definition of
fascism is when private concentrated
economic power takes government away
from the people turns government into a
guarantor subsidized or a covering of
corporate power and corporations now
have their executives in high government
positions they have thirty five thousand
full time lobbyists here like the drug
companies getting all kinds of subsidies
from Congress and they have ten thousand
political action committees now if you
look at the specific side there's
there's very little of that although as
this conference showed they've achieved
an enormous amount given their small
numbers I think basically if you could
quantify corporate power and civic power
in Washington DC civic power is probably
one percent
of corporate power and yet look what it
is achieved and I think the hope coming
out of this conference is not only that
we have a lot of solutions that we don't
apply in our country because
concentration of power in the hands of
the few
allows the few to decide for the many
but we have a large amount of unused
Democratic power unused civic power that
can be unleashed organized to take back
our government if people stopped
believing that they were powerless which
they are in bread and ever since we
entered elementary school you know the
old phrase you can't fight city hall
just to understand how we've come to
this point and where you feel people
need to go can you give a thumbnail
sketch of the history of corporations in
this country how they gain this level of
power well they were first chartered in
their modern form Massachusetts when
they textile companies wanted the
corporate entity to give limited
liability to their investors and so they
were chartered each one at a time into
existence by the state legislature in
Massachusetts and that was in the early
19th century and decade after decade
these corporations began to be powers in
and of themselves they were no longer
after a few decades chartered by
legislature they were chartered by the
state agencies and in 1887 they got just
what they wanted a declaration by the
Supreme Court without even an argument
by the head of the the representative of
the railroad in the Santa Clara case a
declaration by the Supreme Court at
corporations these private entities
would have the rights as persons as
human beings under the Constitution and
then it was off to the races then every
single right that human beings have
under the Constitution was given to
corporations except the right against
self
criminais ssin and so throughout
American history if you take every
social justice movement except the GI
Bill of Rights every social justice
movement whether it's anti-slavery
women's right to vote the farmer
populist movements the worker movements
in the early industry in industries and
the drive for decency justice equal
rights proper livelihoods health safety
who said no the overwhelming power who
kept saying no to the abolition of
slavery was the commercial interest the
cotton plantations the the chief
opposition to women's rights were not
just misogynist
it was the industries because women were
in the forefront of abolishing child
labor and trying to advance social
justice and of course who was against
the farmer populist progressive movement
most prominently the banks in the
railroads and who was against the mine
workers and the auto workers it was the
corporations and in the 20th century the
same thing who are our main opponents in
the environmental movement the worker
movie the democracy movement the Clean
Elections movement that health insurance
for everybody movement
it's the corporation's who have achieved
the power to say no and make it stick so
it doesn't that tell you what our
priority should be if we want a society
where people have the opportunity to
fulfill life's possibilities isn't that
tell you what the priorities are which
is focusing on subordinating the
corporate entity to the sovereignty of
the American people as its employed in
the constant
so
so so that they are our servants not our
masters so that they have to compete
against other models of economic
development
like cooperatives like replacing the HMO
insurance companies with full Medicare
like decentralized solar replacing more
and more of Exxon and Peabody Coal and
the nuclear industry like a redefinition
of efficiency in productivities if
people mattered not as if corporations
dominate they actually define our
economic terms and if we define
deficiencies if people mattered we would
have a massive energy efficiency program
which would of course reduce the sales
of Exxon and Peabody Coal and
Commonwealth Edison and all the rest
because we would be using less
electricity unless gasoline because we
would Democrat eyes technology instead
we have what Andrew Kimbrough called at
the conference these giant corporations
are dictatorships and they have enormous
power without anywhere near the
commensurate responsibility
they are highly autocratic dictatorships
that prevent constitutional rights from
being with workers when they go to the
workplace they lose their constitutional
rights when they enter that corporate
domain and because of all this it is
interesting that our political leaders
don't like to discuss it I mean every
politician is town knows who runs this
town they know who runs a defense
department the Department of Interior
Department of Agriculture Food and Drug
Administration and there are only a tiny
handful of politicians who will raise
the banner of subordinating corporate
power to the sovereignty of the American
people the debates are sterile the
debates are exercises in parallel news
conferences repeating ad infinitum the
same words and phrases of evasion
they will not confront the corporate
crime wave they will not confront the
destruction of our democracy they will
not
from the usurpation of our electoral
processes even though they could go back
to Abraham Lincoln Thomas Jefferson
Teddy Roosevelt Federal Franklin Delano
Roosevelt and others who have condemned
corporate power as a perilous threat to
even a modest Democratic Society
so if corporations or dictatorships you
have a choice of regulating a
dictatorship or getting rid of it well
you've got to do all these things for
example you have to strengthen the
traditional tools that have curved
corporate crime fraud violence outrages
bigotry and these are regulation
adequate opportunity for litigation
these are antitrust which has been
caricatured but it is a powerful tool if
it's adequately applied you have to give
the owners the mutual fund people the
pension shareholders more power they are
the owners but the corporation but they
have no power
just imagine the violation of
capitalists principles these guys at the
top who are paying themselves ten twelve
thousand dollars an hour in compensation
as CEOs basically have repudiated the
cardinal principle of capitalism which
is a few owned property you should
control it and now they have said to
their owners get lost don't dare tell us
what we're going to pay ourselves after
all we're only your hired hands and and
so that's a very important front or
initiative we ask ourselves why not more
cooperative with the Internet you can
develop cooperative purchasing and
develop specifications for the kind of
cars or the kind of insurance policies
people should be able to buy we need
stronger trade unions we need trade
unions unlike SEIU we need trade unions
like the California Nurses Association
who see themselves as a powerful
counter go under billing explain that
difference SEIU is if the inheritor of
the tradition of company unionism the
service employees service employees
andrew stern
I mean basically spends more sometimes
you think spends more time with
corporate executives he does with
workers he's constantly trying to
collaborate with corporate executives in
ways that weaken the morale undermine
the rights and horizons of workers and
most prominently the way he signs these
full-page ads with the US Chamber of
Commerce and all the other corporate
lobbyists saying
Americans should have universal health
care yeah more universal health care
gouging more universal health care
exploitation not full Medicare for all
and the nurses the nurses want full
Medicare for all they want patient
rights they want adequate staffing and
hospitals they want to cut the giant
compensation of these HMO CEOs down to
appropriate size they've run initiatives
in California they haven't won for full
Medicare but they represent what
unionism should be flat out
representation not just of workers but
also of consumers who workers serve so
how do you nuns regain momentum power at
one of their lowest points now in
history one is they've got to mount an
assault on the WTO and NAFTA WTO NAFTA
are basically an albatross around the
neck of workers of consumers and of
clean environments to begin with they
they are an end run around our courts
and regulatory agencies we couldn't have
gotten air bags under WTO because that
would have been considered a unilateral
move under this global trade agreement
and a non-tariff trade barrier would be
considered to highest standard imposed
on importing cars even though it's the
same standard on domestically produced
the WTO does it prevents us from being
first in the world it pulls down our
standards so our workers have to compete
with brutalize child labor and third
world countries
it makes us impossible to prohibit the
importation of products from child
labour that's a violation of a WTO even
though you can't buy a product here in
the US made from child labor in the US
it is the greatest loss of sovereignty
local state national and American
history and it's an autocratic system
with secret courts and secret
equivalency procedures I mean it's just
a total contradiction and subversion of
our democratic society so that's the
first thing has to be done to invoke the
six-month notice of withdrawal and
renegotiate pull up trade agreements
where we pull up the rest of the world
and our standards instead of pull down
trade agreements that subordinate health
and safety to trade agreements that's
the first time that's ever been done you
trade usually stuck to trade trade
agreements now they've become very
imperialist and they've subordinate
health and safety and consumer
environmental and worker rights the
second thing has to be done is something
no democratic politician will ever utter
except maybe for Dennis Kucinich not one
democratic politician will say we should
repeal the notorious anti worker
taft-hartley law of 1940
explain what it is
which basically obstructs the
organization of unions which transfers
control of Union pension funds to
management with all these trillions of
dollars imagine the power that can that
workers could have they would on the
third of the New York Stock Exchange
they would to be able to put real muscle
in investor ownership and it prevents
workers from helping one another called
secondary boycotts among many other
notorious provisions and here to show
you how that it is on the 50th
anniversary of the taft-hartley law I
called up the afl-cio and wrote to the
heads of the major unions in the United
States saying let us remind the American
people in the American worker how
important it is to repeal taft-hartley
and he wouldn't come along they wouldn't
have demonstrations I told him there are
two reporters one Labor reporter for the
New York Times and Washington Post
looking for an event educate the young
generation about this notorious anti
worker law and he wouldn't go along so
again it's the rank-and-file that has to
take over their own union leadership and
the California Nurses Association is
showing the way I wanted to ask you
about the secret trade deals that are
being made behind closed doors between
the Democrats and the White House that
reports Sayre being the language being
drafted by the white house rick
macarthur publisher of harper's said on
democracy now that congressman Rangel
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi are saying
we're gearing up for the 2008 election
we've got to raise a lot of money
they're closer to the Clinton wing of
the party which is the pro so-called
free trade wing of the party the pro
math NAFTA Pro permanent normal trade
relations with China part of the party
and this is a way of saying to the
corporate community Wall Street Walmart
we're open for business we want to raise
money from you in order to compete for
campaign money the logic goes the
Democrats have to cater to big corporate
donors the corporate Democrats in action
again why should we all be surprised
when you ask Court Democrats in Congress
how are you doing against the
Republicans in the
election the first answer is about money
it's not about justice
it's not about agenda it's not about
mobilizing people it's about dialing for
corporate dollars these two parties have
sold the US government and the American
people to the highest bidder and that's
why we have a corporate sovereign
political economy and that's why workers
are daily in peril of losing their
Economic Security and their pensions and
retirement or their jobs or their health
and safety in the workplace you know we
have to pay attention a me to something
very important and that is the language
we are in the process of seeing the
corporatization of our highways the
corporatization of our water systems and
still people on our side uses the word
privatization they use the word
white-collar crime instead of using the
word corporate crime they use the word
private sector instead of corporate
sector we have to stop using the words
of the opponents because they control
the language and Democrats should use
the words corporate welfare more often
they should talk about cracking down on
corporate crime fraud and abuse that are
ripping off Medicare and Medicaid and
the US taxpayer across the board but you
can say that ad infinitum but they're
not going to do it as long as they view
their electoral processes in terms of
dollar signs can you talk about the
corporatization of water yes this is an
area you never thought the corporation's
would temper would penetrate you thought
public drinking water systems in towns
and villages and cities around the
country represent a public function that
water shouldn't be for profit it
shouldn't be for sale like that and
because of the under investment in
public drinking water systems and we saw
this even with our work on the drinking
water act in 1974 that they did a lot of
these systems have deteriorated so
instead of our government saying let's
divert some money from the enormous Lea
wasteful defense budget let's start
taxing corporate crime and corporate
pollution and corporate speculation and
get more revenue for example if you buy
food furniture clothing appliances you
pay a sales tax in this country six
percent seven percent but if you buy a
million dollars of General Motors stock
you don't pay anything so we can get
revenue for public and bus investment
this way if we just got rid of corporate
welfare
that's a several hundred billion dollars
a year so it goes back into clinic's
drinking water systems libraries public
transit the the kind of necessities for
ordinary Americans in their circulation
and ordinary daily life and so instead
of doing that along comes Goldman Sachs
along comes the Heritage Foundation
along comes the right-wingers in
Congress and saying hey let's let's sew
off these systems let's convert them so
that there'll be enough investment to
upgrade them well the history of
converting Atlanta's public water supply
has been a disaster it's been a disaster
around the world but it just shows you
how brazen these corporations are
they're undermining parental authority
bypassing parents selling these little
kids junk food junk drink violent
programming all the things that aren't
good for their little minds and then
teaching them how to nag the parents so
we we are corporate izing our entire
culture and and society in contradiction
I might add a very well appointed
conservative values not just progressive
values and every religion major religion
in the world who's warned about giving
its adherents too much power and if
their merchants watch out don't give too
much power to the merchant class because
it's so singularly motivated and focused
it will trample the great human values
of organized society not just health and
safety or access to justice but simply
the free
the freedom to work out problems between
real human beings without the corporate
supremacist taking over Ralph let's talk
about nabbing the elections that's
National Association of Broadcasters the
money you mentioned that these
candidates are raising tens of millions
of dollars will be well over a billion
dollars in 2008 what would you see as a
different way for the media to play a
role here how do you see the media being
challenged explain how the process works
right now right now the media focuses on
the horse race who's raising the most
money the people the candidates who
raise the most money get the most
attention they get the most specific
polls and the ones who aren't raising
the money even though their record is
far superior and their rhetoric is far
superior like Dennis Kucinich and Mike
Gravel
they don't get hardly any attention so
so the the networks and the mass media
have bought into the wealth election
that's one the second is they have made
possible a private form of corporate
government known as the Commission on
presidential debate so the this
commission was created in 1987 as you
know to get rid of the League of Women
Voters which sponsored presidential
debates and they went around they got
money from Philip Morris and Ford and
AT&T and Coors beer and they they now
control the main gateway to tens of
millions of Americans no matter how many
states you run it as a third party or
independent candidate if you don't get
on those debates you don't reach tens of
millions of people and who is the
gatekeeper the Democratic Republican
parties who even kept Ross Perot off in
1996 after he got 19 million votes in
1992 I called him up and I said Ross
how's it feel for a billionaire to be
excluded he said he says absolutely
right so I couldn't even buy thirty
minutes of airtime they refused him to
buy thirty minutes of airtime
so he could do his charts now you know
on the deficit and and yet these these
TV stations are using our property we
own the public Airways we're the
landlords they're just tenants and they
use our property free they don't pay as
much as you pay for your auto license
and they decide who is on and who isn't
on TV or on the national debates so if
you don't break that connection between
the debate Commission and ABC NBC CBS
FOX CNN you can't break the power of
this corporation called the debate
Commission and have more diverse debates
with more voices and choices which by
the way the American people want in the
in the era in the year 2000 at least
three national polls had a majority of
people wanting me and Buchanan on the
national debates and I don't think
that's just because people wanted to
stay awake but the part of it you didn't
mention is that this two billion dollars
that looks like will be raised for the
2008 elections a majority of it goes to
paying for ads exactly yeah the majority
and then they make money the networks in
the stations make an enormous amount of
money off of the candidates it's really
a it's such a you really have to admire
their ingenious brazen nature this is
what the citizen movement has got to
work on just in terms of dynamic
complicated schemes to take over more
and more of the people's power these
corporations than their law firms
it's like 24/7 just to keep up with them
and and now they don't care if it's all
on 60 minutes or the mainstream media as
long as the mainstream media does not
cover civic resistance movements or
Civic reconstruction movements which
they do very little locally state and
national code they be covering the
resistance to themselves yes
they were they they they don't cover
anything they don't cover the criticism
of themselves you have occasional
congressional hearings on the media as
Jeff's gesture has pointed out in his
new book and guess what they don't cover
it on the evening news
I often wonder which there's a major
demonstration around every major
television station in New York rallying
and making these points they just
surround the building with layers and
layers of people and science I wonder if
on the evening news the television
station would cover it I mean after all
there's weather to cover there's sports
to cover there's five sequences of
weather that starts in the Cascades and
comes over the Alleghenies and you know
all the suburbs 51 degrees here 52
degrees there why would they cover a
demonstration but that's something
people out there should consider get a
demonstration and surround the
headquarters of the local TV station and
see if they cover it you have to show
how brazen they are they may cover it
who knows they may cover they they you
never can tell they're very adaptable
on the issue of corporate power let's go
through the leading Democratic
candidates and where they stand Hillary
Rodham Clinton Hillary Rodham Clinton is
a corporatist she's on the susanti she's
on the Senate Armed Service Committee
didn't lift a finger against major
corrupt unnecessary weapon system
contracting or even weapons system hey
there are people all over the Defense
Department who think we should scrap the
f-22 the Raptor which is now over 250
billion dollar program it's the plane
has gone from about 40 million to almost
200 million he could put two or three of
them in this room and she's never taken
on any any of the corruption the fraud
even though she complains that there's
not enough Pro money for children's
programs well she's on the Senate Armed
Services Committee she's signaling that
she is gonna play ball with the
military-industrial complex she's never
taken a stand on corporate subsidies
handouts giveaways bailouts
you know stadiums in New York subsidized
by taxpayers while so much in New York
City is crumbling for lack of repair and
finally she doesn't even do what Spitzer
did her fellow Democrat gave her cover
by prosecuting Wall Street crooks rode
all the way to the governorship in a
landslide election based on his
prosecuting corporate crooks people like
prosecuting corporate crooks and she and
she won even sponsored tough corporate
crime legislation and tougher penalties
law and order for corporate crooks in
the US Congress so to be kind to her one
can summarize as saying she is severely
lacking and political fortitude
she knows she's the front-runner and
therefore she's going around the country
pandering to powerful interest groups
and flattering the people no maybe
they'll get tired of it after a while
maybe they'll say enough is enough do we
want eight more years of the Clintons
and you know you get it to fir what it
what does that mean eight more years of
the Clintons how would you summarize the
clinton-gore years the clinton-gore
years were they further allowed and even
encouraged with this reinventing
government movement the further
consolidation of corporate power agency
by agency department by Department eight
years went by and there wasn't a single
chemical control standard issued by OSHA
initiated by the Clinton administration
58,000 American workers died from worker
related disease you think they'd at
least issue one and there's a big
backlog of them there's been a lot of
scientific work done they didn't do it
they didn't issue one fuel efficiency
standard where was Gore Gore knew about
this he called the internal combustion
engine in his first book that came out
in 1992 a major threat to the planet but
when he was vice president he was either
muzzled or went along with Clinton who
right from the beginning signaled to the
auto companies you got an eight you
gotta you got a four year
in fact we're going to spend a billion
dollars subsidizing a joint program
which was a complete waste of money to
develop some sort of improved engine
efficiency a partnership between the
White House and the three auto companies
so the the clinton-gore years were the
final evidence that the Democratic Party
is now a wholly owned subsidiary of
giant corporations with the very with
the few with with a few luminous
exceptions like George Miller Dennis
Kucinich some of the older Democrats Ed
Markey and but even Ed Markey has lost
some of his vigor in the
telecommunications area Washington DC is
corporate occupied territory the the
Democrat Republican candidates are
fighting against one another to see
who's going to go into the White House
and start taking orders from their
corporate pay masters when are we going
to understand that either the people are
going to control our government or we're
going to cede control increasingly to
global corporations that have no
allegiance to America no allegiance to
communities other than to control them
or abandon them as they see fit to
Communist China with the industries or
elsewhere we really have a very serious
crisis in our country people have to
start making connections they have to
start spending more time energy on their
civic responsibilities from the local to
the national to the global and there are
plenty of good citizen groups begging
for more people to join their efforts to
expand their resources
you mentioned Al Gore he's seen as the
major voice now on the environment I
don't know if it's exactly on taking on
corporations but he was in power for
eight years so what is your assessment
of Gore candidate for president Gore has
been environmentally reborn is he is
experiencing important redemption he is
doing something very important
he's now basically a full-time citizen
alerting the world to the peril of
global warming and getting some pretty
muscular forces behind them behind his
efforts maybe he'll be restrained in
terms of what needs to be done in terms
of the democratization of Technology and
the expansion of solar energy I stood in
line waiting for you know the book
signing when he came here in Washington
were 300 people at a bookstore and I
just stood in line and finally got up to
his desk and he was very cordial you
would anybody who thinks that the greens
cost Gore the election should ask Gore
he not only won the election he knows
how it was stolen from and he knows he
made some very serious failures himself
including not winning his own state of
Tennessee which would have put him in
the White House but he's very cordial
and I said to him Al because I've known
him since years ago I said how's it feel
to be liberated he said very good and
that's really the description of his
present state it's quite the testimony
when he had real power
he couldn't deploy it you're saying he's
reborn now but he wrote that critical
book in 1992 the fate of the earth so
that was before he I mean during that
time he was in office if he were to
become president what makes you think he
would remain reborn he wouldn't
the only politicians who are liberated
once they're elected are those who come
out of mass movements so that they know
who they're accountable for and we have
a electoral system where everybody
tosses their hat in the ring and then
goes around trying to raise money and
expects people to be spectators on their
campaign voyages through their cities
and States instead of participants
that's what they do they do they don't
campaign with the people with the
citizen groups with the struggles at the
local level against pig farms are
blowing off will mountaintops for the
coal industry or the South Central LA
and the poverty and so on they parade in
front of the people and that's that's no
way to win elected office and expect to
represent the people Barack Obama great
capacity he knows the score he knows who
has power in the country
he was a community organizer in Chicago
after a sterling record at the Harvard
Law School he could have gone and cashed
in but as he said in his book how can
you keep raising that kind of money from
those kind of interests and not have
affect you and he's down to race with
Hillary to raise three hundred million
bucks it's trying to do a lot of it on
the Internet small amounts but he's
going to one economic sector interest
after another raising money and so the
question is whether he's going to
mobilize the people or he's going to
parade in front of the people and if he
does that he's not going to be a
distinguished winner if he wins I was
very upset the other day when I heard
him say publicly that he wanted to
expand and modernize the military I mean
really the military needs more Trident
submarines huh it needs more aircraft
carriers it's already half of the budget
the operating budget of the US
government and there's no major enemy
left the Soviet Union is gone unless you
think Moldova is a threat
and Communist China is converting into
from criminal communism to criminal
capitalism they want our jobs and
Industry they're not going to send
missiles over here so of course other
perils are being wildly exaggerated and
provoked into further expansion the
so-called war on terrorism and the
criminal war in Iraq which even Bush's
CIA chief and general Casey and others
have said are provoking the insurgency
enlarging and attracting more people to
be trained in sabotage and terrorism
from other countries that's a real
that's a real powerful anti-terrorist
policy you pursue a policy against
terrorists with state terrorism you
pursue a policy against terrorists and
expand the number of terrorism I mean
this this this this should be a concept
that could be easily enveloped by the
limited mind of George W Bush John
Edwards Edwards making a good point on
poverty and that was a no-no with
Democratic xx you look at Clinton
speeches all middle class he never would
say poverty he never talked about 50
million Americans in real poverty and
tens of millions of more Americans in a
state called a category called near
poverty and but you know he's got to
become much more populist in a much more
specific way he should become the
solar-energy candidate he should become
the free communications candidate he
should become the affordable housing
more specific not just you know the two
Americas and above all he should become
the law enforcement candidate against
the corporate out was the corporate
exploit
and he knows how to do that but you know
he has to raise money too
Rudolph Giuliani and I might add he's
not good on foreign policy Edwards is
not good on for Rudy Giuliani Rudy
Giuliani is the OneNote candidate and no
one has ever made more political capital
out of what one might be called 9/11
show up mention I mean what did he
really do he showed up which is quicker
than Bush did right he did nothing for
the massive contamination of the lungs
of the firefighters fact he he opposed
their full compensation rights or the
police or the volunteers he he just
turned his back on these people there
have been very good books read deflating
the fraud of Rudy Giuliani
he's also an authoritarian candidate
don't bet your civil liberties on
Giuliani he thinks the Patriot Act is
weak so it's a real authoritative
language if you look at the language
that he's he's conveying around the
country it's it's the frightening John
McCain John McCain he's good on auto
safety he tries to do something on
campaign finance reform although he he
plays the game and has to raise it from
the K Street lobbyist he's terrible on
the war I don't know what got into this
in mind of his I mean he had great
authority to be as good as Senator Chuck
Hagel on it and to say it was the wrong
war and he could have opposed it but
he's stuck and that's why he's gonna
have trouble of even getting the
nomination and if he gets it he's not
going to get elected the American people
will not elect a Republican in 2008 but
they will definitely not elect a
Republican who is for continuing the
role of war in Iraq 70% of the American
people will not want out of Iraq that
means a very sizeable chunk of
conservative voters want out of Iraq and
all the Republican
of any significance that are running who
are running want to continue that war
they want victory the unannounced Fred
Thompson Mayor Bloomberg Bloomberg is
they is the wild card he could easily
turn it into a three-way race if he runs
as an independent
there's talk of a Bloomberg senator
hagel ticket and that that could not
just be another Perot rerun it could
really be a winning ticket
you know Bloomberg is a surprise to most
people and he's got a Republican label
he's a former registered Democrat I
don't think he's good on corporate
welfare but he's got a way where he
could really appeal to people who call
themselves Republicans independents
Democrats he is big business so he's not
afraid to talk Turkey to them if he
wants to nobody can say didn't meet a
payroll but we're still waiting to see
whether the insight Bloomberg office
talked about running is actually going
to materialize the independent
unannounced s-- Ralph Nader
it's too early to say I if I was going
to run and I have not decided at all the
biggest problem is getting on the ballot
the Democrats filed 21 phony suits
against us we won most of them but it
was very draining
they in Pennsylvania they got a
democratic judge using a Republican law
firm Reed Smith to assess me and Peter
Kumail $81,000 in transcription costs
and handwriting expert fees for
defending our right to be on the ballot
which they got got us off to all kinds
of shenanigans first people in American
legal history who had to pay court costs
for defending the right to be on the
ballot so ballot access obstructions is
the political bigotry of American
politics it's very hard to get liberals
who love civil rights and civil
liberties and who are Democrats to be at
all excited about the systemic
obstruction of 50 state laws at one
level or another that can be used by
either Democrat Republicans against
third party candidates and historically
Amy that's where all the great ideas
came from in the 19th century was the
anti-slavery party that women's suffrage
party the farmer party all the things we
read about briefly in our history books
that pushed these social justice
movements before one or both of the two
parties picked up on it so they're
really it's you know I like to say what
would happen the nature if it prohibited
seeds from sprouting what would happen
if big business could totally extinguish
on small business that's what the big
two party elected dictatorship is doing
to a whole array of local state and
national candidates who would like to
give the American people more voices and
choices so I asked you about individuals
running but you talked about individuals
being a part of mass movements what
about the many people in this country
who are not running but do want to
determine who represents them how do you
think mass movement should organize
themselves and hold politicians
accountable make them more accountable
to citizens civilian non citizen
movements than corporations well let's
start with the easy things like half a
democracy is showing up so why don't
workers who have lost their jobs of
their pensions to industries that have
gone to communist China with us to farm
of Commerce subsidy and encouragement
why don't they mass and rally I mean
who's keeping them from rallying in
masse American Idol is that what's doing
it I mean let's stop making excuses for
ourselves let's take the farmers the
dwindling number of farmers they have
great important causes that mesh with
environmental causes at the times then
the whole issue of genetic engineering
and the dispossession of the small
family farmed by the big suppliers
corporations and the big buying
corporations why don't they come to
Washington the way they did 20 years ago
with their tractors show up why for
example can't a coalition of existing
groups the urban coalition n-double-a-cp
the trade unions the consumer the
environmental groups the neighborhood
groups in each setting sponsor
auditorium sessions for the major
candidates or whatever candidates that
want to invite that are going through
New York or Boston or Houston or Denver
Los Angeles or st. Louis or Miami they
couldn't turn them down and they could
say we want you to be here at the
auditorium to respond to our agenda
we're the ones who are going to say no
we're the ones they're gonna say yes we
know about your agenda it's very
abstract and we can always get it on the
web site we want you to react to our
agenda now is that hard to do they
couldn't turn it down because all of
these coalition's struggling to
piecemeal improve conditions in their
communities represent hundreds of
thousands of people know is that too
hard to do I mean this is this whole
idea of rationalizing our futility it's
got to stop we we have far more unused
rights and powers already left in this
country that we're not using
how do people get involved in the
elections you say people should show up
people should be organized without just
furthering supporting an individual
candidate who's beholden to no one
whether they're Republican or Democrat
and not challenging the the whole issue
of raising the what is expected to be
more than 2 billion dollars for 2008 for
the elections the first step is to get
rid of the least worst voting mentality
because a lot of people vote Republican
Democrat they don't particularly like
the parties but they know one is going
to win
so you vote for the least worst so many
of you are at least worst voter and your
greatest concern is the worst of the
least worst you basically tell the least
worst candidate that that candidate can
take your vote for granted because
you're not going to make any demands and
you got nowhere to go so the voters have
got to start asking themselves how can
we condition our vote so when you get a
coalition in the city like I just
mentioned inviting the candidates to
their auditoriums covered by local press
the demands are made in that fashion in
the year it's year 2004 we looked up 19
groups that supported carry Edwards they
were environmental groups poverty groups
women rights groups in all of the labor
groups not one of them made any demand
on Kerry Edwards why this is so freaked
out by Bush therefore by not making
Kerry better
they allowed Kerry to be worse pulled by
the corporate interests 24/7 who don't
have this kind of squeamishness and
therefore there weren't enough bright
lines between Kerry and Bush and there
was a lot of waffling by Kerry Edwards
and in the first debate he out hawked
Bush on Iraq will never pull out of
Fallujah and two months later after the
election Bush obliterated flu that's
nice cover by the Democrats so you have
to make demands on your least worst if
you don't want to vote for an
alternative
and those demands in many of these
elections will be very very compelling
they can't turn down these kinds of
existing liberal coalition's have the
corporation's won well they certainly
they've won and they're winning but they
can be defeated they can be overcome
they can be displaced by all the things
I just mentioned the Sun is a great
displacer of the oil cartel
really if only the Sun could speak world
come and run what have they taught us
and what do you think is the most
effective strategy that you've seen at
the smallest community level or at a
global level for taking on these
greatest powers on earth well first of
all they're they're very powerful
because there's a minimal organized
resistance there's a lot of criticism
poll after poll shows the people are
turned off on the issue of the pollution
of their surroundings degradation of
their working situation the abandonment
of the country the commercials
ionization of their children etc it's
not organized so it's got try
organization try going with the existing
groups that are small and make them more
and more powerful the conference that
we've just concluded on taming the giant
corporation was full of suggestions of
what's going on you see they're not
exactly glamorous they're not highly
sensual that's the problem in democracy
that the most important quests are often
described as dull run through them well
for example a local credit union in a
poor area in a city that is reviving the
neighborhood the democratization of
credit you know a developmental credit
union for example the expansion of
farmer markets where food has grown
close to where people live and not
transported thousands of miles and
therefore subjected all kind of
processing chemicals and loss of
nutrition you know that's expanding
- we've got buildings that are being
built with greater energy efficiency
they're just not there not being
aggregated and if you don't aggregate
them you don't build morale like we hear
a lot about Exxon and and and their
pollution and we can't hear enough but
do we hear about the interface
Corporation and Atlanta the largest
carpet tile manufacturer in the United
States with plants here and abroad at
the head of that company Ray Anderson
Roy Anderson has since 1994 moved the
country toward the company toward the
goal of zero pollution and 100%
recycling in so doing he's reduced his
own costs and thrown the gauntlet to the
other corporations with the message by
respecting the earth and not pillaging
NIR and recycling and cutting pollution
you actually reduce expenses improve
worker morale and make more money yet
you see you don't see that widely
publicized so we're not publicizing the
operating models of superior performance
sufficiently you do that on your program
once in a while but look at the average
nightly television news I mean how do
you satire satire it's a character of
itself so community radio increasing
there are a lot of things that gar
alperovitz has put in his book but we
need a broader concept which is that we
have to displace the the corporate
sovereign political economy I use the
word political economy because it's
politics and economics they dominate we
have to implement what Businessweek
magazine said in an editorial in the
year 2000 quote politic a corporation
should get out of politics and quote
exact words this is the major business
magazine in America and we have to stop
making excuses for ourselves and put
some real material reality in the old
song the people have the power
by Patti Smith because they do have and
they only have the power if they believe
they have but if they absorb the
corporate party line forget it
you can't you don't count you know you
can't make change you have to hit one
two three one two hit button one two
three and just be a basically a
compliance surf because you may you may
be discomfort if you take on big
business then the companies don't have
to work overtime to overpower the people
the people who overpowered themselves I
want to end with health care I think one
of the critical issues of the day that
is so rarely explained if there was a
health care system in this country that
you designed what would it look like
well it would look like full Medicare
for everybody
whereby the government is a payor the
government now pays over fifty percent
of the health care bill huge amount of
waste and fraud inflicted by these
corporations on Medicare and Medicaid
for example drug companies getting all
kinds of corporate subsidies so they're
already the government is already over
fifty percent federal state and local
government so it's folk god it's called
a single-payer which means it can it can
almost eliminate two hundred billion
dollars of computerized billing fraud
and abuse which has been documented by
the General Accounting Office and by the
leading expert on this who should be on
your program Malcolm Sparrow a lecturer
at Harvard University and when I said
200 billion mr. Sparrow every year he
said that's the lowest estimate that's
just computerized billing fraud and
abuse in the health care industry it
would dramatically reduce administrative
expenses dr. dr. today was at the
hearing today no yesterday I guess and
she said that the per capita
administrative expense in this country
in health care is almost $1,900 in
Canada it's over it's under $500
so it's more efficient it's less
corporate crime
it covers everybody it saves lives
18,000 people die in this country
according to the Institute of Medicine
because they can't afford health care
that's six 911s every year and the
outcomes are better in Western countries
the outcomes in terms of infant
mortality in terms of life expectancy in
terms of lower levels of anxiety they
don't have to worry about losing their
life savings for a tragic illness are
all better than the United States system
and what would you what do you think it
would take to achieve this we take about
a million people spending 800 million
hours over a period of two years and key
congressional districts you got about 25
percent of Congress already for it
and once the Washington politico's hear
the rumble of the people you will see a
change that will surprise even the
cynics among us they got to hear the
rumble of the people and about 2,000
organized people in each congressional
district connecting with a popular
sentiment that's all for this and they
can give you chapter and verse in their
own family in terms of tragedies due due
to the health care system denial
malpractice corruption insensitivity
deferral it can happen you know we
should always remember Richard Nixon he
came into office in 1969 and all he
could do was hear the Rumbles of people
and he was so scared of liberals people
called him paranoid
the Liberals themselves were surprised
how scared he was of liberals and the
quote liberal media remember well look
what he did because he heard the rumble
the people from the great demonstrations
in the sixties and early seventies he
sight signed EPA in the law osha into
law he had a health care proposal better
than far better than clinton's didn't
make it through Congress
he had an anti-poverty program that had
a national minimum
income for the poor Americans didn't
make it through Congress he had a drug
control law that focused more on health
than on incarceration and he so any
supported voting rights in Congress for
the District of Columbia now you think
he believed always he heard the rumble
of the people and we all got to be part
of that rumble and the first thing we
can get and the fastest thing we can get
is full Medicare for all people
understand Medicare which is being
sliced and undermined and depleted of
course with the recent legislation where
the government subsidizes gouging
corporations to undermine Medicare they
actually use your tax dollars to
undermine Medicare and make more profit
for these corporations that's what the
Democrats somehow couldn't stop and
Congress a couple years ago like UDON's
black they couldn't stop the tax cuts
for the wealthy or the war but that's
the first thing we can get because it's
perceived as necessary as life-saving by
so many people every Western country has
a version of it including Canada but
whenever you propose full Medicare in
this town that come the people who even
support and say it ain't gonna happen
how many times they say it ain't gonna
happen what do you mean it ain't gonna
happen you got to show the rumble of the
people don't make it happen
last question before you end with a few
words Ralf does george w bush matter
anymore
yeah he matters because he's a national
security menace he's a he's a he's a
destroyer of our constitution a violator
of our statutes a revoke of our
regulations
he's a warmonger he is a war criminal
clinically a war criminal and he's still
in charge in and and as I said some time
ago he's a giant corporation in the
white house masquerading as a human
being although I sometimes wonder about
the word human I I don't think it's
possible to see a more obsessively
compulsive our country including
conservative traditions that's why so
many libertarians and conservatives like
Pat Buchanan have opposed them again and
again what's important is to basically
get back to self-determination do we
really believe in self-government do we
really believe in accountable government
and do we really believe that the
supremacy the people has to be re
installed over the supremacy of what
Jefferson called the moneyed interests
in which today are the giant
corporations and I think that in
addition to the various tools of
accountability that we've discussed here
at this conference such as regulation
litigation investor power public
delivery systems when the corporation's
aren't interested like the Tennessee
Valley Authority stronger labor unions
organize consumers cooperatives here's
what we really need in a broad sense we
need to exercise the ownership that we
already have of the great public assets
of the United States of America from the
public Airways to the public lands to
the government's research and
development to trillions of dollars of
labor pension funds all of which are
owned by the people and controlled by
corporations and so that's no big deal
there
radically is it to revert control back
to the owners that's a basic
conservative principle the second thing
we have to do is increasingly displace
the operations of corporations with
better operation more efficient energy
more renewable energy more credit unions
that are accountable to their small
investors more Medicare replacing the
HMOs all over the country we see
examples of displacement of corporation
and that is really a very powerful and
exciting movement if it obtains a
magnitude of significance and in the
third we have to structurally
constitutionally every way subordinate
this robot called the corporate entity
not its employees or its people the
robot has to be subordinated to the
supremacy of human rights of real
individuals and that shouldn't be a hard
sell either if we start talking about
these things more often if we don't
leave it up to Democracy Now to talk
about it if we don't leave it up to an
occasional TV you know an occasional
TV and a kid very occasional TV we have
to increase our expectation levels it
all starts with increasing our
expectation levels of what kind of
society we want and what kind of world
we want to bequeath to our descendants
if we're not motivated enough for the by
the past great reformers and civic
patriots of our past the fighters
against slavery women's rights and all
the rest of the social justice if that
is enough to motivate us then just look
around this country and see the
tragedies the dispossession the
injustice the exclusions the disrespect
the gouging the ripoffs the using of
taxpayer dollars against those small
taxpayers themselves the lack of Health
and Safety the hundreds of thousands of
lives lost every year in occupational
disease
medical malpractice and air and water
pollution and denial of health care and
so on who weeps for those people and we
have to stop making excuses for
ourselves that's the key we have to
multiply our own Civic energies with our
neighbors our relatives our co-workers
our friends when that happens when word
of mouth takes over as the prime
communication system in this country
nothing can stop it we have to replace
Big Talk with small talk and we have to
make it apparent to millions of people
that striving for justice is one of
life's greatest gratifications in fact
outside of the family it is the greatest
gratification without justice there's no
such thing as liberty and freedom
there's no such thing as fulfilling
life's possibilities and I want to thank
the people who came to this conference
and lent us their energies and energized
themselves and hope they'll go
throughout the country and do the same
thing thank you